[Music]
don't let the title of the presentations
fool you although we are going to be
focusing on an automotive use case which
we think is a great use case for IOT
there everything that we talk about is
going to be applicable to lots of IOT
industrial energy use cases so there's
definitely something here for everybody
and the three things that I think we
hope that people walk away from from
this session are number one is do you
really walk away with a sense of what it
takes to succeed in IOT from business
perspective right number one number two
is a real-world example with whatsa be
she talking about their Mitsubishi
connect program and the real value that
they're creating for themselves as a
company and their customers and then you
know we're super happy to announce our
partnership Google clouds partnership
with Eris and where you're gonna hear
both their full-stack IOT platform and
how that helps customers navigate a lot
of the complexity and IOT rapidly
innovate and just deliver that value
really quickly to customers so that's
basically what we have in store for you
over the next 50 minutes sound good all
right all right good crowd
okay so if you're here you're here for
IOT and the good news is IOT is growing
so just a quick stat that I pulled from
company called IOT analytics that does
competitive research for IOT industrial
IOT and Industry 4.0 is showing that of
for enterprises that they surveyed where
as 12% of enterprises back in 2018 had
said they had implemented IOT projects
that that number is increasing to 50% by
2021 so a couple things I think take
away from this stat is number one
there's growth right and it's still a
little bit early in now to you but
there's there's a lot of growth
happening there's a lot of innovation
happening this is a very good time to be
thinking about IOT and specifically you
know one of the things that we see
really clearly is this transition where
a lot of companies are moving from a
proof-of-concept phase and pilot phase
to real deployment of
two solutions in production and over the
next three years you're gonna see this
you know clearly increasing it's just a
stat that kind of indicates that but you
know this growth does beg your question
and the question I think it begs is so
how do you be successful in this growth
how do you take advantage of it so I put
together this framework having had the
benefit of being in IOT for here over
the past six years developing an IOT
platform and you know being here with
Google and many of our customers
outlining what we call the seven steps
to business success in IOT and it's
basically a framework a way to think
about how to navigate the daunting
sometimes set of business considerations
technical considerations and even
sometimes cultural change that has to
happen within a company or customer base
in order to really be successful in IOT
so I'm gonna step through this quickly
and you know there's a lot more behind
it but you know let's just kind of start
at the the first part the business case
so the first thing about the business
case is you have to have one what you
know I think the biggest indicator one
of the biggest indicators of success
that we've seen in working with
companies who have embarked on the
Scioto journey is that the companies
have answered three fundamental
questions really really well number one
is who is my customer number two is what
is the new value that we want to deliver
to them with it connected service and
number three is how does that new
customer value then fold back into my
business and add value to my business
and ideally some way to really measure
that and and show clear ROI companies
that have done that work I've just
really set very well to make many of the
other business decisions and technical
decisions a lot more effectively if not
you know we jokingly in my team would
refer to something called the IOT
cul-de-sac which is not a dead end road
but it's kind of like you get down the
road for a while and you realize you
haven't really thought through your
endgame and you I don't have to turn
around and go back and start from the
beginning so number one number two is
the connected product itself so this is
it for OMS who are often the ones
implementing IOT
Lucian's this is the one that can sound
easy because that's what you do you make
a physical product but when a physical
product becomes part of a 24 by 7
connected service there can be all sorts
of new considerations as you can imagine
you know the question is you know with a
connected car is it a car with a
computer in it or is it a smartphone on
wheels right what what really is it and
you know this this has impact on
everything from mechanical design you
know are all the buttons and knobs that
you would normally have still needed if
you're now gonna control those virtually
or via an app right that affects the
electrical design electronics design
connectivity design right you're gonna
use wired networking Bluetooth Wi-Fi
ZigBee cellular which type of cellular
right we're in which regions low power
wide area networking all these
considerations that come just into the
physical product that are different that
and then if it's not a a part of a
correct solution the cloud platform as
you're picking a cloud partner right
does that partner bring the global scale
security tools capabilities that you
need to have to be the platform upon
which a lot of this solution is built
and the user application so it's kind of
an interesting one because if you look
at 2 & 4 right user applications and the
connected product these are two areas
where you're you're building the part
that will interact directly with the
customer and one is physical and one is
digital and you have this kind of
interplay between the physical and
digital world and in IOT as you know a
lot of the value starts to shift from
the traditional physical product into
the digital world but this brings up
some opportunities of course but also
some challenges and maybe if some
culture changes I think Brian you'll
talk a little bit about this because you
develop software a lot differently then
you develop hardware but they have to be
in sync with each other right so
sometimes there's even a cultural change
in a company that has to take place here
then you know the next step you know
hopefully when you're embarking on an
IOT on the IRT journey you're not just
building a connected product but you are
really running a connected business for
the benefit of your customers and
this often means how do you integrate
data from these services into business
systems that you use to run your
business every day if that's a CRM
system if it's a marketing automation
platform if it's a an ERP system if it's
you know ticketing system right trouble
fixing but you know that's something to
really think about the capabilities of
those platforms and the limitations also
and how that that ties into the equation
you know next you know who's heard I Oh
tea is all about the data right yeah
show of hands the hands were a little
weak everyone started that or did is the
new oil we had to change this to be a
little more renewable and if we should
start saying an IOT date is the new
sunshine that's it's a to to soft data's
a new sunshine I think I think we could
let's tag it right now that's first time
it was said right but the point is that
IOT is more than just connecting devices
and connecting people there you know
there is a lot to can be done and needs
to be thought out with the data what
types of new insights can you derive
that you can never derive before what
understanding of a customer can you have
that you were never able to have before
and this blending of IOT with smart
analytics artificial intelligence and
machine learning is absolutely a trend
that we're seeing and we think you know
the the industry is evolving towards as
well finally and you know this is
probably the most overlooked when a
company goes after the opportunity of
the IOT the companies that also do a
really good job of thinking about the
obligations that they now are taking on
by becoming a 24 by 7 service provider
is is really important because they you
know in balancing the opportunity and
obligation when you're 24 by 7 service
provider you have a different support
expectation from your customers they
expect that 24 by 7 and if you bake that
into the business case on the solution
you're you know you have you have the
whole thing together so it starts and
ends with the customer starts and ends
with the customer so two more quick
slides and then I'm going to pass it on
if you're with if you spend much time
with me or my team you're going to hear
that you cannot know
company can do IOT alone and what we
jokingly say but seriously say - is this
always three legs to the stool -
implementing a an IOT solution there's a
platform an enterprise-class platform
like Google cloud platform there's the
foundation upon which Lada is built then
there's an ecosystem of partners of
best-in-class partners that really
provide hardware software connectivity
and those pieces that really either fill
in gaps or accelerate innovation from
from customers your eros is a great
example of a partner that provides this
full stack I have T solution with Google
cloud you'll hear a lot more about that
and then you always need pro services so
platform partners and pro services
because no solution is complete you
always need experts either domain
experts or technology experts to help
bring it all together so we as Google
cloud with respect to IOT we never
engage with customers without bringing
in partners we're always bringing in
partners and there's always the three
legs of the stool are always there to to
stand up a solution and lastly you know
I'll spend the least amount of time on
this but if you look at from the
platform perspective what Google cloud
brings is you know a set of managed
services that allow companies to connect
millions of devices ingest that data
process clean store that data and then
develop those insights and business
outcomes that you want as a plan this is
you know a platform that with the other
two legs of the stool find it brings the
whole solution together for customers so
with that I would love to hand it off to
Brian who's going to tell you a little
bit about species great thank you
good morning everyone my name is Brian
Arnett I am I need this thing as you can
see I am actually I'm a product planner
I've been a product planner for the OEM
industry for over 25 years
I've worked with currently working with
Mitsubishi Motors and was recently
tasked about two years ago to
investigate as part of the product
planning
at Mitsubishi Motors to get into this
telematics game we saw a lot of as you
guys know there's the General Motors and
and a lot of the OEMs out there are all
talking about connected cars and what
connected cars means to the OEM industry
and we needed to figure this out we need
to get part of this game so we started
to investigate the telematics industry
and we started talking with many
different suppliers including Eric's and
what we quickly learned is that the
biggest lesson of all is we come from
two completely different worlds in the
automotive industry we have been
building cars for a hundred years
using waterfall approach to engineering
our engineers are basically ingrained in
their methodology and go through a
series of waterfall check-ins and so
suddenly when we start bringing in IOT
into the on-board environment into the
vehicle we start to realize that we need
to blend these two worlds together we
need to have some type of a hybrid
approach between waterfall development
and agile development and so what we're
finding is that there's two cultures and
we as an automotive manufacturer we need
to learn how to be more agile and you'll
hear that from probably a lot of OEMs
out there from the automotive side
you'll read that how automotive
manufacturers need to think faster need
to move faster to be competitive and so
by partnering with ares and working on
the IOT space we actually learned how to
improve our culture from an engineering
perspective to implement more an agile
approach to our development and start
rethinking basically how we develop
vehicles from a more agile point of view
not just a waterfall point of view so
like any good connected car program we
had you know we need to start with a
vision so what is it that we want so
essentially we encapsulated our vision
as the car will be integrated into the
IOT network by advanced connected car
technology of Mitsubishi Motors in the
future our connection
of each other and the world around us
will only grow we will be part of the
Internet of Things connecting you more
directly to your world
Mitsubishi Connect will provide
innovative connected services by
applying the information network to
provide a more personalized enriched
driving experience and what is really
important here is the statement where it
says we will be part of the Internet of
Things connecting you more directly to
your world so a lot of times
manufacturers think of things as a
hardware perspective we connect a cell
phone to a car and we do a remote engine
start and we're done
what we need to start thinking about is
connecting the customer to the car not
just the devices and so this is also
something that automotive OEMs are
starting to think about is how do we
connect our customers into our world not
just bring our device bring their
devices into our car so that's something
that is very important as we also look
at what is our strategy going forward
the u.s. traditionally has been the
largest market for telematics services
in the United States almost all om major
brands now have some sort of some sort
of aggressive fitment penetration in
connected cars and as you know
traditionally most of the automotive
profitability about you know over a
majority of it is traditionally gained
by fixed operation expenses sells of oil
sell of parts maintenance services
things like that with the growth of
electric vehicles rapidly you know real
being realized in the marketplace some
of these traditional fixed operational
services and some of these traditional
revenues are going to disappear so we
need to start thinking about new
business models and new ways to generate
new future service revenues for things
in the automotive sector and becoming
more connected to our customers and
delivering more on demand related
services through IOT you can see from
the chart here which is provided by SPD
automotive by 2025 over 90 percent of
all vehicles shipped to the United
States will have an embedded connected
and also a smartphone tethered device in
the vehicle so within a very short
period
time within the next five years or so
virtually every vehicle shipped in the
United States will have some sort of
connected device so you're looking at
you know a SAR of about 17 million new
cars sold every year so by 2025 you're
gonna see a rapid expansion of IOT and
services being offered in the automotive
space so we have only five years to
really learn how to get this right so
from a Minister beeshees perspective we
we looked at it from kind of a
three-stage approach and I guess this is
kind of like your stool first we looked
at it from phase one perspective so we
introduced something called a smart
phone linked display audio most people
know this is like Android auto we
introduced the Android auto capability
into our vehicles and we have a tethered
smartphone system in our vehicle where
we can do custom om applications that
are approved by Google and can be
downloaded from the Google App Store and
put on your cell phone and so forth then
beginning in 2018 just last year we
introduced Mitsubishi Connect which is
basically at ECU or a telematics control
unit or an embedded device that is
installed into the vehicle and then next
or our phase 3 we get into more of the
analytics and this is where we are going
to start learning more about our
customers how to service our customers
and how to grow our business and then
the service or attention of our
customers through the analytics that
we're going to gain through both the
data that comes from the TCU and the
data that comes from the tethered device
so today
Mitsubishi connect system is in the
market and launched about a year ago we
offer two-year we call safeguard and
remote service bundle with the purchase
of any Mitsubishi vehicle that is
equipped with this so safeguard services
include things like automatic collision
notification SOS emergency assistance
roadside assistance stolen vehicle
tracking remote services include things
like remote climate control remote door
lock car finder parental settings things
of like that all of which offer
connectivity through your smart phone
and you can see
the application there in the center we
also offer Google home capability where
you can use Google you know talk to your
car
through the Google home device to remote
start and so now we're starting to
establish a relationship between the
customer and the car more directly when
you're not in the car
and so that's very important typically
OMS only were able to make a
relationship or establish some kind of
connection with the customer when they
were driving and when they were in the
car now we're able to start establishing
some type of a relationship and starting
to be able to provide some branding
exercise to those customers when they're
away from the car and so when they have
their smartphone or they're at home in
the morning getting ready to go just
simply ask Google to start their car pre
condition the climate control so some of
the key business challenges that we
faced that we were looking at Mitsubishi
generally is a much smaller company then
you know then the Toyotas or the
Volkswagens of the world so economies of
scale were very important and necessary
for us to make a valid business case it
talked a little about earlier about
having the business case so of course we
had a business case and we knew right
away that in order to make this work we
needed to do it on a global scale we did
not necessarily have the volumes only in
the United States so we didn't have the
volumes only in the European market so
we needed to look at this from a big
global perspective and so that we
started looking at what kind of
partnerships we could have in that
perspective and quite frankly there
weren't many with expect with the
exception of maybe Eric's so we needed
somebody to deliver automotive-grade IOT
services on a global scale we needed we
needed a vendor to help us to provide
technical leadership and manage the
complexities that we were quickly
realizing as an automotive manufacturer
we weren't experts in IOT we were car
guys we needed somebody who could help
us become experts and guide us in the
IOT place and lastly we needed somebody
that could be flexible and adapt to the
automotive processes as a change request
that we constantly make we're a
waterfall development company we're
learning as we go we needed somebody
that was flexible
and easy to work with and understood
that we're learning along with them so
one of the partners here that it will
speak next two areas and they have
delivered on a lot of this for us and
have been able to be really instrumental
in in helping us manage the complexity
and helping me and our team at
Mitsubishi worldwide learn the IOT space
the next thing we needed was Mitsubishi
needed an end in modular solution that
could adapt globally and grow at the
speed of of the feature innovation so we
needed to look at the the stack of
technology that was available and here's
basically a picture of Ares full stack
of services so the edge client the
connectivity manager the IOT transition
services the core services all the TSP
services including the call center
operations you can see the complexity
gets quite overwhelming from an
automotive manufacturer so we need
somebody to handle all of this and then
we also needed somebody who would be
able to be flexible with this stack in
case something were to change in the
future or be able to adjust this stack
so this is one of the one of the key
requirements we had of a supplier and
then lastly as I mentioned we needed the
ability to work with our mo partner we
currently work with AT&T the mobile
network operators to provide seamless 4G
LTE connectivity sim provisioning
turning on the HA the SIM chip turning
off the SIM chip managing the subscriber
statuses all of that needed to be done
the call center off the authentication
tool needed to be developed from a
global perspective not just in the
United States but also in in Europe and
around the world and then we also needed
we needed a kind of connectivity a
connected vehicle ecosystem that
provides significant that provides a
significant set for hackers basically
the industry needs to have a secure
vehicle right as we start getting into
the IOT space and we start bringing the
outside world kind of into our vehicle
one of the biggest concerns of of an OEM
is the security
of the vehicle obviously we are a very
heavily regulated industry I think
there's a government agency for just
about everything related to the
connected car with Nyssa or the Homeland
Security or Department of Transportation
or whatever we are constantly having to
report to the government authorities and
so here comes IOT and we're all God on
what government authority do we have to
report to now when it comes to this so
security is one of the things we
definitely wanted to make sure we had a
good handle on so we need to secure the
vehicle while protecting the driver we
needed the ability to update the
hardware our affe and our services
without inconveniencing our customers
and we needed to be able to
differentiate services based upon the
identity of the primary owner or the
secondary owner or whether it was a
fleet customer or was a retail customer
we have many different types of
customers when it comes to purchasing
vehicles and so it's very important when
connecting a car to not just connect the
car but to connect the customer and so
in order to connect the customer we have
to know who that customer is we have to
be a little control and manage that so
that's very very important and Ares has
delivered on many of those areas so
that's a little bit for me I like to
turn it over to Drew and he could talk
to you a little bit about the technical
side of the IOT integration Thank You
Bryan and thank UI we're so proud and
grateful actually to have Mitsubishi as
a customer of ours it's it's fantastic
and I'll just say we we use the word
automotive grade those words actually
has a bit of a proxy for reliability and
security and complexity and we're really
happy that you know even though this is
a very mature market actually relative
to too many IOT markets that our
platform we're winning among quite a few
automakers which is actually very
difficult to become a supplier of
automakers so so that automotive grade
really does mean something so if we if
we kind of go through
several of the key challenges that that
Brian mentioned one of them is
complexity and actually complexity is
one of the key challenges overall in the
Internet of Things it's it's very
difficult especially for OEMs who are as
Brian mentioned generally their business
has been about making Hardware
potentially for a hundred years like in
in in the automotive space and trying to
get to services and software can be
really challenging and there's a lot of
complexity in that this this picture
over here on the right is just one view
of some of that complexity there's
there's other views that you know
different different views of how that
complexity takes shape and one of the
things that that Mitsubishi did that was
that was pretty smart to help manage
that complexity was they created what I
kind of think of as this pyramid of
responsibility so they really only had
two main suppliers they had eros and
they had their hardware tcu provider and
then they counted on those two providers
to deliver everything else so if you
kind of go back to to Mario's picture
pretty much everything else was
delivered by those two providers so Aris
we delivered the platform with all of
those remote operations and the
analytics that that that's there the UI
is the mobile UI and the and the the
smart speaker U is the call center the
cloud actually in the connectivity we
managed all the connectivity as Brian
mentioned and then along with the TC
provider we actually shared
responsibility for the firmware and I'll
talk a little bit more about that in a
minute okay and then here on the right
this is a picture of our Stax very
simplified picture of our stack and if
we if we go to again one of the key
challenges that that Brian mentioned of
how do you how do you actually
deliver rapidly both for the initial
launch and then even being able to add
additional services ongoing if you think
about a car it's in the market for 10
years so you really don't want to have
those those features frozen for 10 years
and you have to have an architecture
then that that can support that agility
not just in the delivery of the initial
vehicle but actually on going over that
10-year life cycle so this this
architecture is key I'll just walk you
through really quickly each one of these
kind of major box boxes here has
actually something like 10 to 20 micro
services in it so I'm not going to go
through all those but I will walk you
through generally how the architecture
looks so starting down here the the edge
client that's actually software running
in the vehicle so that's actually where
we collaborated with the the TCU maker
to allow us to put that edge client in
the in the vehicle and that is if you
look at kind of previous generations of
connected cars that is relatively unique
a lot of the previous generation
connected cars did not have an edge
client that was really an extension of
the cloud platform they actually just
aligned on api's or protocols and that
that actually is one of the areas that
causes problems with being able to
develop rapidly and actually extend the
services and platform eventually later
on so we have the edge client we have
our connectivity platform so our
connectivity platform we'll talk about
that in the next slide the device
platform is actually again really key
for being able to abstract the the
vehicle from the rest of the services so
the edge client the edge client includes
capabilities like connection management
authentication authorization OTA all of
the
the the local interfaces to actually
perform remote operations all of those
capabilities are here but it
communicates back and forth to the
device platform in an abstraction that
allows us to just make changes here
without having to make changes in the
full device platform or even in the
service platform so very key for this is
actually getting that abstraction
correct and we've seen a lot of
platforms again where there's there's
tight coupling especially between here
and here or maybe even between here and
there between the the service platform
and the and the and the edge client that
actually constrains that those eventual
developments okay and just a quick note
if you if you think about the IOT core
the IOT core actually is part is one of
the micro services here in the device
platform that's part of the
communications infrastructure all right
and then from a connectivity perspective
eros is actually you know we we provide
connectivity for the Internet of Things
in many many horizontals so we have
customers and are many many verticals we
have customers probably in every single
Internet of Things vertical in the
market and what we've seen for you know
with with many years of experience is
generally you know particularly large
programs they fall apart if the if the
customer really does not pay attention
to connectivity if you if you really go
into the market and you think cellular
connectivity is more or less similar to
Wi-Fi or wired and you ignore the
complexities of cellular connectivity
then you'll run into problems at scale
there will be problems if you if you
really just think about it you know it
if you have problems maybe with making
calls or connections in a particular
room of your house you can always move
to another room or or reposition
yourself but a car can't do that you
know car sitting in your garage I can't
do that so you need to have a
connectivity management platform that's
really optimized for handling the
Internet of Things which is very
different than you know the what you
need for consumers and consumer handsets
and then there's other aspects of of
cellular that come into play like you
know security and we'll talk a little
bit about security in a minute being
able to optimize the the response times
across the cellular connectivity you
think about a remote operation on your
vehicle you need to have it happen
quickly rather than and actually you
have to balance the speed and user
experience with the power management
that's going on in the vehicle as well
and as Mario mentioned as as we as we
moved to you know from 3G to 4G even on
into 5g and particular and potentially
even incorporating Wi-Fi you need to
have a connectivity management system
that can actually handle all of those
different modes all right and then one
of the other challenges that that Brian
mentioned was security and in in with
regard to the security need to really
take a security domain approach there
are actually at least eight major
security domains in the connected
vehicle space and each one of those
security domains needs attention
independently and then you need to make
sure that you cover the full supply
chain if you think about from the time
the car is created until the
time the car is crushed there's so many
different parts of that lifecycle that
come into play and each one of those
stages in that lifecycle needs to be
secured and then relative to
connectivity again if you ignore
connectivity something that we see again
from from have seen from from customers
in the past that connectivity is a
really critical part of the security
domain again a relative to a cellular
cellular it was designed to be a
many-to-many type of communication
mechanism if you think about it so you
have to apply the security mechanisms to
make turn that many-to-many into a
secure private network mechanism and one
of the the most famous pacts actually in
connected vehicle in the last few years
was at least exacerbated by the fact
that that the connectivity security
domain was ignored so there was a in
that case there was a hole in the
vehicle on the edge which in itself was
was bad but what happened was the the
hole was exposed via connectivity so
that anybody who was on that
connectivity provider could actually
access that hole and it's key here
actually to assume that you're never
done
you have to regularly scan and and that
that's also why OTA updates are so
critical all right and and then the last
thing I thought I'd spend a few slides
just talking about why Eris is moving to
GCP and we're really proud as mario
mentioned to become a partner
of Google and last year like perhaps
some of you I was sitting here at Google
next and we were contemplating you know
potentially moving to two GCP and
ultimately I just want to share some of
the reasons why we chose to make that
move so number one we think of cloud 2.0
is really kubernetes if you think about
cloud 1.0 being really about virtual
machines primarily cloud 2.0 is about
kubernetes and of course Google is is
creator and the biggest contributor to
kubernetes but in particular GCP has
really a large lead on managed
kubernetes so if you look really across
the the cloud providers and you do your
own evaluation like we did you'll find
that in managed kubernetes Google
actually has a very strong lead and the
way we look at it is and I you know I
love our DevOps team but if I have to
make a choice of hiring one more
DevOps person or hiring a data scientist
I'd rather hire the data scientist and
getting a good managed kubernetes
infrastructure in place allows us to
control really our DevOps workload the
second reason is about really being
customer and developer friendly and you
know I go back to this this this quote
at the bottom that that's my quote
actually if of cloud 1.0 ROI is if you
think about those ROI is those were
really about you know having your own
private data center where you had tens
of usually operations kind of usually
standard operations folks and the ROI is
were relatively easy for kind of
reducing a large number of operations
folks and moving those to be DevOps
folks in the cloud but now your CEO or
when you say when I say your CEO I mean
my CEO is actually saying hey we're
still spending too much money in the
cloud what can we do that's that's an
improvement and again as we as we kind
of look around the the industry at
different cloud providers what we see
out of DCP is that you know just from
cost transparency and kind of
optimization ease there are really large
advantages in GCP and I think you can
you can get to to some of these same
capabilities in some of the other cloud
providers but not nearly as easily and
for us in our our kind of old cloud
provider we actually ended up with 15
separate accounts in order to manage all
of the access controls and have cost
visibility the cost visibility that we
wanted and what we see in GCP is it's
just tremendously easier to more
automatically get that visibility the
access control and the cost
optimizations that we're trying to get
to and in the last the last big reason
is we do see this opportunity to
actually collaborate with Google and
their customers on making the Internet
of Things less complex and easier for
OEM so you really see that nearly every
single om on the planet is on this
journey from unconnected product to
connected service and that's really
important that difference between that
those words product and service as Brian
mentioned often times in the in the
automotive space the only interaction
that the the actual automaker might have
is maybe even just
at the point of the dealership and that
might be the last interaction that they
have with the customer previously so the
fact that they can they can have a
connected vehicle they can understand
how the the consumer and the owner is
actually using the vehicle they can have
opportunities to interact with the owner
on a regular basis is really it's a it's
a game changer in the business and in
the business of many OEMs so for us we
see you know some of the areas that
we're working with provisioning at IOT
scale in a secure way seamless
connectivity and OTA updates of edge
devices I've mentioned a few times about
why that's important in the space the
advanced remote operations services if
you think about especially in the moving
things area the the fact that you have
you know mqtt and and an IOT core and
and some of those things those are those
are great but it doesn't make sense for
every single OEM to reinvent how remote
operations are done a lot of that needs
to be more standardized and shareable
and leverageable and then the automotive
grade edge computing where if you think
about the future where again the the if
you think about web web 1.0 - web 2.0
and web 1.0 you also had more of very
rudimentary kind of logic getting pushed
to the edge to your browser and then
kind of interacting over rudimentary
api's back to the platform that's a
similar thing that's going to happen as
in the in the edge computing area so
that we have the edge computing logic is
more of a adaptable updatable set of
logic that can get easily pushed to the
edge
interact in a really optimized way with
the the cloud-based platform so these
are some of the areas that we're really
excited about working with with Google
on and being able to to provide - to
some of Google's customers
[Music]